ここ耳を出そうと思ってここめっちゃ切ったらなんか
あーなんか違うんだぁーってことをよく美容室でありませんか
なので自分で切ったけど結局失敗したっていうねまあ今日はそういう話じゃないんです
よ
皆さんまずあつってますかこれはねもう知ってる人は知ってると思うんですけど
ライブ昔ですもう僕の父さんくらいの世代のときにエッジセーバーファミコンで実は
ゲームがあるんですよ
まず厚
そんな混ざっってのはまぁ普通の普通ではないですシンプルなロールプレイングなん
ですけど
うん
rpg 子は今のところさイチョウです
ネットにもよく口コミがあって未だに mother 2を超える rpg が出ない
とか言われてるほどの rpg なんですよ
あのツバスブラザーズのピンセット分かりますバット振ったりなたはを燃やしたりする
ようなの子供がいるんですけど花子が主人公のゲームたんですけど
なんとあーなんとですねその mother 2のガチャだから
ならちょっと前ライブも去年から出てるらしいんですけどやっと
オレンジの家っての道キホーテでも見つけてもう井筒数えました
まだ中身を見てないさまだまだ見てないんですけどちょっと味なアレよねー
ポケモンポケモンが楽しいああ違うんですよ
マザーズやってで奴はマジでもう rpg 語れないんですよもうボケェ
まずは通話も食べつっ10週1は全クリしてますから
がなってみます
回復アイテムの量の多さと町の人のコメント取ったのすべてがもう右4ビルでぜひ
mother 2やってない人やってみてください wii u のバーチャル
コンソールでも多分できるのでぜひやってみてください
じゃあ開けます
全6種全6社製ですよだめ the まず
版5を狙うはとりあえずベースを支援です
とりあえずよニール目です自己ベストオーラと z ぷさんこの4人が出ればもうも
ok です
どせいさんと頑張りすぎじゃないんだよわぁお星さんでした
ん
参加 massive ランダーでどせいさん投げる奴だったけどマジでプレイありえ
ないんだけど星さまであげるもんじゃないってもうスマブラで女性さんは泣けないで
ください
一応今開けたんですけどこんな感じですねすぽー拉致フッっと生産ケップ
帰ってきたケップ鼻血な本尊とか指キャッチも好きなんですけどまぁずーってる人
悪い奴はいないと思ってる俺も
それぐらいなんかわーよしよしどよめく食べる一人一人
ジェフですいやチェックか
ペンシルロケット要因ですよごめんねちょっとまだつ知らない人からしたら次これ動画
ですよ
[音楽]
食べなよ
おおあぁ
あでも可愛らしいけっつーですとん
この可愛い感じわかりますハーイとしあいみつをかけたい
もうこの時点で4人その後だけだったんだよ
プーだけは出て欲しくないんだよ部は出て欲しくないんで愛想
d jester そうな使えるけどさ
あーもう見えてちょっとムースが見えたからプーさんう
カー一風です
ブーブー言っはティ
ソースかすごくランサー強くないですがベースが出ればいいもう
メッセが出ればいい
くそだということはポーラとん
帰ってきた玄武快適プレイヤーって帰ってやるレアなのは帰ってきたキャップ
欲しくなってきた
もっと書いていこうかな嫌ならここがんです
まだ2が教えてくれた幸せになるために頑張ってな幸せじゃないんですよ
僕はも人間種からねっ
[音楽]
ああいう意味で1回200円なんですけど
めっちゃこの書く
うんそうでもなかったですねこの額はないんですけど mother 2が好きな方
どんげにつけたってちょっと他の同期誰か分からないんですけど
花ちゃんのコーナーに普通に置いてありました
結構な旅スケなかったんですよ
ああああああ
見つけた時を超え立っちゃったらねそしてまぁざっと知らない人
1回でいいからちょっと最後までやってみてください音楽もいい生街並みもいいしてき
もなんかかわいいして
ちょっと怖いけど
いいんですよ
誰でも楽しめると思います
[音楽]
じゃん
me
[音楽]